en un pasado vídeo os hablamos de como
teodoro obiang y su familia había
secuestrado guinea ecuatorial' explotado
los recursos del país a beneficio propio
y acumulado una fortuna mil millonaria
no olvide que en este país no hay
pobreza habría lo que yo califico como
penuria con todo ello han condenado al
pueblo guineano el pueblo marco de
áfrica amor vivir en unas condiciones de
extrema pobreza en este vídeo queremos
profundizar un poco más en el tema y
analizar cómo funciona el régimen de
terror que bajo una cínica apariencia
democrática ha consolidado el poder casi
absoluto de la familia obiang yo presumo
de que soy un dictador
porque el sinónimo de dictador viene de
dictar las normas y es que hablar del
gobierno de guinea ecuatorial supone
hablar de un entramado de corrupción
camuflada como un estado que utiliza la
represión y la conducta criminal para
lograr sus objetivos así lo indican no
solo los informes de ongs y la
información procedente de la oposición
política sino que la propia secretaria
de estado de eeuu ha publicado un
informe en el que denuncia la total
ausencia de respeto a los derechos
humanos que profesa el señor obiang yo
he visto como maltratan a personas como
si fueran animales atarlos y colgarlo de
los postes como hacerlos romperles las
manos las piernas y los pies reventarse
los a base de golpes pero como ha
consolidado su poder a teodoro vean cómo
ha convertido a guinea ecuatorial en una
especie de cárcel colectiva pues
fundamentalmente aplicando una
estrategia de terror que podemos
clasificar en tres campos principales la
libertad de expresión asociación y
reunión están muy restringidas ejercer
la posición activa o participar en
política puede tener consecuencias
nefastas de hecho el pasado 24 de abril
se celebró como denominarlo una farsa
electoral la que teodoro obiang obtuvo
más del 93% de los votos nosotros
tenemos la aceptación del pueblo de
guinea ecuatorial los comicios
estuvieron marcados por toda una larga
lista de irregularidades por ejemplo el
censo contenía inscritos a menores de
edad y no presidentes por supuesto la
oposición no tuvo acceso al mismo y es
extraño porque todos los miembros de la
junta electoral fueron hombrados por
bien eran miembros de su partido e
incluso la propia junta era presidida
por clemente engonga ministro del
interior además de todo esto la
principal candidatura de la oposición
fue suspendida se han sumado a nuestra
lucha por la democracia por la libertad
por los derechos humanos y tienen miedo
igual que yo durante la celebración de
estas mismas elecciones se cerrarán
organizaciones como el centro de
estudios e iniciativas para el
desarrollo una de las pocas asociaciones
civiles independientes por si esto no
fuera suficiente dos días antes de las
elecciones unidades del ejército y la
policía de malabo rodearon la sede del
partido ciudadanos por la innovación y
retuvieron en su interior a más de 200
personas muchas de las cuales fueron
finalmente arrestadas y golpeadas
tres heridos en un ataque del ejército
de guinea ecuatorial a la sede opositora
no resulta extraño entender como obiang
pudo hacerse con la práctica totalidad
de los votos al final cualquier persona
que muestre desafección o sea crítica en
este supuesto gobierno democrático se
expone a duras consecuencias como perder
su trabajo ser perseguido por la policía
o incluso ser encarcelado pero esto le
puede pasar hasta a los amigos del
régimen es el caso de roberto vera de
que se atrevió a preguntarle a su socio
teodorín que había utilizado la sociedad
que tienen en común para blanquear
capitales en eeuu esta pregunta acabó
con su libertad y hoy roberto berardi se
encuentra en la prisión de black beach
una de las prisiones más duras del mundo
y una tortura prácticamente reporteros
sin fronteras sitúa a guinea ecuatorial
en su inicio de libertad de prensa en el
puesto 167 de 180 por su parte el comité
de protección de periodistas considera
este país uno de los 15 con mayor
censura en todo el mundo ámbito decir
que la coacción el acoso de la violencia
contra los periodistas son más que
comunes incluso en enero de 2014 el
gobierno llevó a detener a dos
periodistas extranjeros del financial
time que ellos mismos habían invitado
para cubrir una conferencia de inversión
el 20 de enero en malabo la capital de
guinea ecuatorial' agentes de seguridad
armados arrestaron a javier blas
redactor sobre áfrica para el financial
times y peter chapman redactor senior
del mismo periódico fueron detenidos y
los equipos incautados por el tremendo
delito de conversar con miembros de
partidos políticos opositores por si
fuese poco las comunicaciones privadas
son monitoreadas y el acceso a internet
censurado muchas webs incómodas para el
gobierno son bloqueadas y su tráfico es
redirigido al portal oficial de prensa
del gobierno
así es como obiang ha conseguido
perpetuarse en el poder durante más de
30 años y los políticos españoles que
dicen de todo esto bueno pues la verdad
es que obvian ha tenido con
prácticamente todos los presentes en
españa salvo con aznar que era
notoriamente mala y con suárez que acabó
del todo bien cuando aparecen intereses
económicos claros como los derivados de
la explotación del petróleo y en
ecuatorial dejan de interesarse por la
falta de democracia por las violaciones
de derechos humanos mariano rajoy ha
sido quien vergonzosamente ha visitado
de nuevo a obvie antes de que felipe
gonzález lo hiciera en 1991 sin embargo
aunque marjah no ha intentado acercarse
el círculo de amigos no habían en españa
podríamos decir que se encuentra entre
las filas socialistas el expediente
zapatero moratinos y josé bono han
realizado visitas privadas de 13 últimos
años para reunirse con el dictador la
última visita de bono de hecho ha sido
escasamente a finales del mes de mayo de
2016 a unas escasas semanas de
celebrarse en las próximas elecciones en
español
bono se reúne en línea con el hijo de
obiang y a su vez se ha querellado
contra el diario rompe para los que no
conozcáis la práctica española jose
bueno es como nuestra hillary clinton lo
ha sido todo presente castilla-la
mancha' diputado histórico en el
congreso ministro de defensa y
presidente el corso los diputados es
razonable que alguien como josé bueno
vaya a reunirse con dictadores para
hacer negocios o lo que quiera que vaya
a hacer por supuesto que está su derecho
de hacer lo que le dé la gana pero esto
en otro país habría ocupado portadas y
habría sido una vergüenza nacional pero
esa vez spain y disfrute
si bien es cierto tenemos a nuevos
políticos que no tienen ningún temor en
denunciar la triste realidad de guinea
como por ejemplo el diputado de origen
ecuatoguineano rita abusado de podemos o
fernando maura de ciudadanos vosotros
qué pensáis conseguir a guinea
ecuatorial librarse de la lacra de los
obvian y bien el desarrollo y la
libertad podemos hacer algo para
contribuir a que eso se produzca yo creo
que sí cuanta más gente conozca qué pasa
realmente allí menos tolerantes seremos
con la actitud de presidentes como rajoy
que van a reunir respeto a dictadores
como vivían en nombre de todos los
españoles esperamos vuestros comentarios
un saludo y hasta el próximo vídeo